this is coming from U.S Energy
Information Administration so this is
not like something that's from a Blog
it's the U.S department of energy okay
so nuclear 92 and a half geothermal is
74.3 natural gas around 57 hydropower 42
coal 40 win 35 solar 24.9 yet that's all
we keep hearing about if you go to the
next one uh the CO2 emissions you you
should have uh yeah that one right there
if you could uh um there you go and then
the last one will be great uh zoom in a
little bit so we can see it all CO2
emissions avoided by the U.S power
industry again nuclear
and that's by million metric tons 476
187 174 45 and geothermal
can you explain this chart right there
go back to the one you were on no just
go on the one that we were on explain
this chart what does this mean to the
average person
so well I'm not sure it means anything
to the average person but let's take a
step back and say if you have more
nuclear power you use less of everything
else now you use a little bit less of
wind and solar but you also use less of
fossil fuels and it means you end up
emitting less CO2 nuclear simply
replaces CO2 emitting energy so that's
why nuclear has saved more uh CO2 than
any other technology if you have more
wind if you have more Hydro you also
save CO2 but much less and what you have
to remember is it's really hard to keep
a society running with wind and solar
because you know they predictably will
run out you know at night there's no
solar when the wind dies down there's no
wind and we have no sense of how little
batteries we have right now the world
has batteries uh to to cover enough
electricity consumption in the world uh
for one minute and 15 seconds so if
fundamentally batteries are not in any
time soon going to be able to step in on
this so whenever you use solar or you
win you inevitably have to have some
backup power that both has greater cost
and that also means typically gas so
unless you're very
fortuitously positioned where you have
lots of hydros back up you will emit
more CO2 so nuclear is the only
large-scale way that we can cut a large
part of our CO2 emissions from
electricity Tom what are you noticing in
private Equity what direction money is
going to with nuclear are you seeing
like a trend there yeah you're saying if
you take a look at at the minds of
private equity and in Venture Capital
you you have people like Bill Gurley and
others like him that are pointing out
that
um investment in you know Gen 4 nuclear
is not only uh important but it's
critical because gen 3 nuclear clear has
proven to be safe in fact you look
around France France has got a ton of
nuclear and it's not old nukes right
it's it's relatively new and so that's
how they're being powered but they're
looking at it as investment
opportunities and you're not seeing
you're you're not seeing a bunch of
investment in like the next two percent
more efficient solar panel
um and you're seeing full recognition
that it's that oh we could just get
lithium from seawater and I said and
then you take a look at the energy it
takes to get the then other resources it
takes to get the lithium out of the sea
water but you're seeing tremendous
interest in investments in in in new
nuclear power and more importantly
evangelists saying will you please read
the reports and I'm seeing VCS they'll
tweet it they'll connect to a report and
say will you just read this will you
just read this and they're trying to
push you know rather than just yelling
or making documentaries that are fake
they're trying to get people to read the
facts such as we're right here and so
they're smart people are out on the
Forefront but they're being drowned out
by the political people
follow up on the nuclear thing we were
talking about this off camera but we
started nuclear is one of those words
where I mean it's just you say the word
nuclear people are like have a nuclear
meltdown like you that's a that's a
taboo word you hear that I mean we all
know what happened in World War II in uh
Hiroshima Nagasaki and then there's been
disasters we were talking about the
Three Mile Island that they kind of
covered up in Chernobyl and Chernobyl
and uh was it Nagasaki or Fukushima
anyway all these situations you hear
nuclear people get freaked out is it
what should we not be fearful of when it
comes to nuclear so uh if you actually
look at how dangerous different things
are uh given how much kilowatt hours
they produce or how much energy they
produce it turns out that nuclear is one
of the safest things ever uh it's it's
it's a little bit like with airplane
crashes uh actually it's incredibly safe
to fly but every time there is a crash
you will hear about it great analogy so
it's it's a a little bit the same way
with you know Chernobyl obviously was a
terrible disaster uh but you know uh 10
years later the EU the World Health
Organization the international nuclear
commission and several other
organizations went together and said how
many people
actually died from this and they find
that it's much less than 2 000 people
you know remember this is in a world
where Coal fire power which emits lots
and lots of air pollution will routinely
kill about half a million people every
year but it happens all the time and
it's not one single disaster so it
doesn't kills half a million people so
the air pollution from coal fire power
uh so it's basically the fact that you
know you've cleaned up much of this in
the U.S but most places you just belch
out this black smoke especially in poor
countries and it simply blankets the
neighborhoods with uh with dirty air for
West Virginia
I don't know about that but if you go to
New Delhi for instance it's terrible
literally terrible you know it's like
smoking a pack of cigarettes or
something a day now that's also because
they burn a lot of their agricultural
waste and you know it's not just the
coal-fired power plants but we know that
Coal fire power plants make a huge
impact uh and and the point is there's a
lot of deaths from a lot of different
Technologies how hydropower very clearly
also leads to Big breakdowns of you know
dams that kind of thing uh and you know
even even wind power and solar power you
know people will uh drop down from the
from the rooftops where they're
installing them or down from the from
the uh wind turbines they're not nearly
as dangerous so you know they're still
pretty good so are you advocating for
more use of nuclears because I'm simply
saying nuclear is incredibly safe and we
should recognize that just like you
actually reckon most people recognize
airplanes are incredibly safe yeah
although that's not I think that's
important distinction because you know
these days you hear what is going on in
Ukraine Putin drops a nuclear threat
every single day obviously there's a two
you know different examples but just the
the word nuclear people like you know
like the hair raises on their skin right
there it's alarming yes yes and and just
because you share a word you shouldn't
think that that's just but it's the same
word so exactly exactly kind of hard to
distinguish the two so yeah and this is
also why fourth generation nuclear power
because remember third generation
actually had to be actively protected so
on you know if you lose all power that
was what both hadn't Fukushima and and
Chernobyl if you lose all power
basically you can get a real meltdown
what they're saying is that the new uh
fourth generation nuclear is passively
safe that is if you lose all power it
just stops which of course is a better
setup there's a lot of technological
reasons why we didn't do it for the
third one because you would be like well
shouldn't we've done that already but
yeah so the the point here is it's
potentially much safer it's potentially
much cheaper but again I want to see
that uh before we we say yay let's go so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]